and now our feature presentation
Lawrence of Arabia presented in its
original ultra cinema scope letterbox
format well I can't see anything with
the rather attractive girl on the camel
that's Peter O'Toole I want to make a
quick video on the usage of aspect
ratios as a thematic device in the film
while the first 40 years of film were
limited to one ratio for length and
width of a screen modern filmmakers have
several aspect ratios to choose from and
each one can have a different emotional
effect for the viewer let's look at why
filmmakers choose the ratios they choose
and explore the emotional effect of
changing aspect ratio during a film
the oldest aspect ratio is the 4x3
Academy ratio and it lost its popularity
after the introduction of sixteen by
nine ratio in the 1950s directors still
use this ratio sometimes though to make
the film feel like it's from an older
time period a great example is the grand
Budapest hotel which switches to Academy
when the story goes back to the 1940s it
begins of course with the aspect ratio
change is a great way to emotionally
transport us to the time period when
this ratio was popular we associate the
aspect ratio with old-timey movies and
it helps pull us into the old timey
style quirkiness manners and culture
that the grand Budapest hotel has 500
days of summer uses Polaroid square
ratio as a way to show a glamorized
reminiscent past this time capsule look
coincides nicely with Tom's
old-fashioned unrealistic view of love
towards the end of the movie though this
Polaroid look is eventually pushed off
screen as Tom realizes the expectation
of this old fashioned outlook does not
coincide with reality 2.35 ratio is
ultra widescreen and it gives the look
of an epic big-budget drama or a sci-fi
film I like how aunty Donna uses it for
over-the-top drama my face is so good
but compared to you he's such a doodles
of robot games I mean here's the app
the ratio is reserved for extremely epic
movies a movie like Napoleon Dynamite
would look kind of off in this extreme
ratio but a movie like Star Wars
wouldn't look nearly the same without it
portraying space is commonly associated
with big aspect ratio changes
interstellar switches to IMAX footage
when the shots are of space and goes
back to sixteen by nine four shots of
the spaceship what better way to make
space look bigger than by literally
adding to the screen the same is done in
Apollo 13 and Galaxy Quest to show the
huge scope of space
aspect ratio changes to add scope aren't
exclusive to space movies though right
before the band verse Batman fight in
the Dark Knight Rises for example the
camera transitions to bigger IMAX
footage this change has a great
subconscious emotional effect it reminds
us subtly that we're about to watch an
intense epic scene Hunger Games also
does a good job of adding anticipation
by slowly expanding into IMAX footage
before the fighting begins the right
aspect ratio can contribute to the
realism of a film a scripted film that's
supposed to look like a documentary has
to be sixteen by nine or else it won't
emotionally feel like a documentary the
opening scene in The Incredibles
purposefully looks like 16 millimeters 6
by 9 ratio film and the effect adds
realism so the movie feels less like a
cartoon and more like a realistic action
film catch me if you can cleverly use
his aspect ratio change to show Frank is
contained he starts on TV in the small
Academy ratio and then he's next shown
through a small slit in a wall he is
literally being squished in the frame it
gives the emotional feeling that Frank
is trapped the most ambitious aspect
ratio changes are when the ratio is
ignored completely Life of Pi has the
fish literally jumping out of the frame
and oz the great and powerful does the
same with a burst of flame it's a really
immersive technique and makes for a
great visual aspect ratios have a chance
to greatly contribute to the visual
storytelling of the film whether they
indicate time period intensity or added
realism aspect ratios are another clever
tool at the disposal of the modern
director if you want to fully understand
the style of a film the film's aspect
ratio is a great frame of reference
thanks for watching